yeah yeah uh then let's talk about Mad
Men I guess all right I know the name of
this show never seen a single episode
yeah it's it's like [ __ ] it's like
advertising right this is like the chat
show before Chad shows exists like John
Hamm plays like a giga track I love John
Hammond but like it's great because
in the show it starts out as like yeah
John uh I think it's all day on the show
he you know he's this kind of he knows
everything he's smart he's killing it
but as the show goes on they they slowly
introduce flaws to him and humanize him
um and in a way that feels great and and
it's about it deals with a lot of the
topics at the time like this is like
1950s it deals with a lot of sexism it
deals with a lot of misogyny uh it deals
with other cultures not being uh
recognized at the time and how that
interacts Mad Men is about Don and the
Ad Agency they make ads for people okay
so a lot of the time the show is just
how do we make this happen newspapers
and billboards and stuff like that big
Brands they're like the premium a grade
yeah marketing company in New York
Manhattan okay well this this is when
like our agencies start to become like a
real oh yeah oh yeah they started
realizing oh if you advertise correctly
you can make like a [ __ ] ton of money oh
yeah right yeah so you know a lot of the
drama comes from okay we're interacting
with this client they have these needs
and how that character interacts and
it's a great way of introducing
characters for a few episodes that have
a big impact on the main cast yeah and
then how that kind of plays out in their
life yeah and there's a great scene that
I feel like after you've lived in Japan
you're like yes I understand this uh
they have like there's a scene where
they like have a [ __ ] uh they maybe
like Toyota or something and what are
the Japanese car brands right and they
made like the Ad Agency compete against
another Ad Agency to make the best ad
and they wouldn't like geek shows I will
not make an ad to compete you will buy
my services or you are not welcome and
they are and it was just like this whole
thing of I will not dance for you I was
like I feel that so much now this
happens so much in Japan we have to do
[ __ ]
wow no no but it's great it's a great
show if you want what what makes it good
what makes it good characters I think uh
like one like like better call someone
which I'll talk about like really good
characters really good writing yeah you
know it's a slow burn nothing crazy
happens nothing explosive happens every
every episode it's just if you like
people talking you like good dialogue
you like development I like good dialo
it's it's just a great show and it's
it's very slow to start with I think
that's the problem with that a lot of
people don't get into it because it
feels like all right when's something
gonna happen but they're just lay in the
foundation I really love Mad Men because
because like I've always found the
advertising world just uh interesting to
begin with I feel like I explained it
poorly but yeah it's it's like
especially seeing like the evolution of
the advertising world like you look at
like the old days in like the 60s or
something and like an advertisement
would literally be here's my product
here's what it does let me list off all
the benefits of using this products and
then yeah like I think like somewhere
along the line I'm not sure if it was
like
likes it must be TV all right you know
it was you know this was this was on TV
yeah but somewhere along the line I
think like the most the biggest example
I can give off is like I can think of is
like the cigarette industry
started like they they stopped marketing
their products and they started like
marketing a feeling a lifestyle yeah
yeah yeah instead of just being like hey
here are cigarettes they're gonna
[ __ ] kill you oh by the way you know
buy our product they're like this is the
American way yeah it's like it's like
Peak 1950s America where they're
figuring that stuff out wasn't it like
uh wasn't it like Coca-Cola that were
like one of the first ones to do it
might have been really just like it's
this is the feeling that you get yeah
this is what it's like it's like the how
it feels to chew five guns it's like
that it's like that [ __ ] you know but
it's great it's a long one it's got like
nine Seasons okay right but you slowly
watched Don's life uh change quite a lot
but it's good it's good though it's it's
worth it I got into it and I I couldn't
stop like it was it was enthralling all
right yeah okay uh we also have future
drama I mean need I say much about
future yeah honestly I was we were all
this I guess we're all this close to
putting Futurama on it's like I don't
know it's like how do you make like it's
like macaroni side I'm gonna make a show
that's funnier than Simpsons has a
storyline has characters that you love
more and just hits every note I feel as
well the humor is a little more geared
towards like the older generation I
think oh yeah because like because you
know Simpsons has a lot of early
Simpsons is very good early symptoms
yeah but like around like comparing it
to The Simpsons during the time that
Futurama was airing like alongside I
definitely felt like they cared way more
about a few traumas yeah yeah it's kind
of like a throwback to more than old
school Simpsons type of [ __ ] right yeah
yeah I mean one thing I've always loved
about Futurama is that they actually
gave a [ __ ] about the Sci-Fi setting
yeah in the world it wasn't just like a
haha here wacky setting ah they're like
there are so many episodes in Futurama
that they really delved into this like
really like Niche scientific concept or
something like that it was basically
kind of like Peak Rick and Morty before
Rick and Morty existed
you know what I mean uh like the
Futurama Futurama rant so Rick and Morty
could walk
I wonder how many Rick and Morty fans
I'm gonna piss off with that yeah I mean
it's especially like when they started
delving into more of the story aspect
holy [ __ ] oh some of the latest some of
the later episodes made me cry yeah like
[ __ ] Fry's dog is gonna [ __ ] stick
with I I mentioned that you know and
everyone everyone has the exact same
reaction just like really funny jokes as
well like using the Sci-Fi setting to
like a huge Advantage yeah like I just
like one of the First episodes right
it's like Bender goes in the suicide
Booth right yeah tries to and tries to
con it and I feel like that tells you
literally everything you need to know
about Bender oh yeah the guy doesn't
want to pay even for his own suicide
we'll try and con it and then gives up
immediately like it's like they just
it's such good writing and and you can
tell that everyone on the team cared so
much about making the show as funny as
possible yeah and I just love it so much
and I love the episode where Fry drinks
like 100 coffees one of my favorite ones
[ __ ] love that episode so much so
that's such a good [ __ ] ever [ __ ]
love that episode so much yeah what I
love about Futurama is just the cast as
well it's just it's it's rare that you
see such a perfectly balanced cast like
like even I think it's like even better
than the Simpsons oh yeah yeah in terms
of balance the side characters
definitely shine in that show and even
like even like the every now and then
characters that you see in like just
some of the concepts that you see like
you know obviously because like you know
because it's Futurama and like mac
raining show it's like okay we'll throw
in maybe like a couple of like celebrity
noddings and stuff like that but the
fact that these like celebrity cameos
make their way into few trauma as just
the head yeah in a gloss it's like
that's that's like immediately way more
funnier than just like here's the
character that you all know and love
that just comes into the frame it's like
yeah it's a little more interesting uh
and then and then I guess the fine uh
two final ones okay sure okay yeah I
mean Jerry come on all right so Arcane
is is fantastic there's like 70 clips of
you guys talking about okay I just think
that Arcane should be watched this is
your weekly reminder to watch Arcane if
you haven't yeah I am I am frothing at
the thought of getting a season two all
right do you really know that you want
to talk about Better Call Saul and I
just think they released it behind the
scenes recently that was fantastic yeah
they really just showed how much love
and care went into it yep
I agree yeah what what you said Connor
yeah what do you say I don't know what
more I can say about Arcane it's a show
that hits the ground running it's good
save me it's uh it's uh Joey's favorite
show I love it all right Hunter and I
came my top two favorites so I figured
that God would would not put breaking
bad because maybe we're going to talk
about it anyway I don't know if maybe
God did for Breaking Bad I figured we're
going to talk about breaking bad okay on
that Universe spoiler I didn't actually
put broken back I've never even seen it
but I figured we would want to talk
about it in some capacity okay because I
mean it's like it's breaking [ __ ] bad
yeah
my favorite are you putting break in
battle are you putting benefits the
universe is the universe the universe
yeah I think like what is that I would
put both of them on here but I feel like
what is that Universal coin okay the
metaverse the the Vince Gilligan
Universe I don't know like the the whole
world of Breaking Bad and better call
soul is fantastic and honestly I mean
the only reason I put medical Souls
because it just finished recently and it
was it was insane it's so good like one
of the best TV shows I've ever watched
like flat out just I mean I've been
watching the show weekly well not weekly
like since it adds weekly uh since I was
in university right because I was
watching Breaking Bad when that was
airing weekly when I was like 15. and I
just think that there's something about
it that I mean it clearly captivates
everyone online as well yeah people are
in love with this world and the show and
I think it's just because of how just
careful and how meticulous all the
character writing is yeah and how you
know there's a lot of twists and turns
in Breaking Bad and embedical soul but
it doesn't feel like it's done for any
particular shock value it's like you
know if a character dies it is a big big
deal and it's dealt with really severely
in the show and a character's death has
such Rippling effect on everyone in the
cast and it bothers them it changes how
they view things and I I can't do it
justice I mean Breaking Bad and medical
assault you probably know all about it
it is just amazing and I hate being that
normally guys like watch Breaking Bad
it's a good TV show but it just is it's
literally it just is an amazing show
yeah I mean I don't know if I don't know
if this is going to be a hot take or not
but like yeah I've seen breaking bad I
think it's an amazing show I have zero
emotional attachment to it which is why
I didn't put it on my list right yeah it
like I think Breaking Bad epitomizes
everything that I guess does not
interest me about TV American TV shows
what what are you wearing where it's
just what do you mean okay kids I'm into
my child already yeah yeah I know I'm
like okay tell me what like like the my
perception of Breaking Bad is every
reason why I am an anime fan if that
makes sense okay where I think Breaking
Bad isn't like I look at it as a Critic
right I think it's an amazing show it's
got so many moving pieces there's so
much care and attention that's been put
into the writing and the themes and how
how the uh how the developments of the
show evolve and everything like that but
it's it's it's polished it's it's to me
it's like it's it's a show that's like
polished to a point
that's it's
I don't know how to say it it's polished
to a point where
it just doesn't interest me is that
weird is that weird bro I never even
gave it a chance you don't want to see
the Pinnacle in like TV storytelling
uh I think one one okay one big thing
again uh is that it's so grounded in
reality right the part of the reason why
so many people are attached to so many
of these characters because they they
feel like like such well don't want your
characters to feel real
he's an isakai fan yeah but like I think
I think it is an extremely tall order to
make characters that feel real and and
somehow Breaking Bad in medical Soul are
Masters at making you care about these
characters oh yeah who are so well
written and unbelievable yeah yeah they
are incredibly well written too like
it's so strange I've never heard anyone
have that complaint yeah I know I mean I
don't even know if it's a complaint
right I'm complaining that the show is
too good which studied God's brain yeah
yeah I mean here's a some sometimes you
love sometimes I like a bit of rawness
in the expression sometimes I like a bit
of unpolished you know unpolishness you
know sometimes I like it when something
is just is not like this well refined
it's too clean this is such a bizarre
argument this is going to build on one
of the shows that I'm going that I've
put on my okay which is okay this is
half of a hot tick right okay I like I
think Breaking Bad is an amazing show
but I I have zero attachment to Breaking
Bad I hear this if you didn't have zero
attachment to it but I could understand
that I just think I I loved it a lot and
maybe it's because I you know when I
first watched it I was like 16. yeah
I've rewatched it since and I still love
it I just think it's just amazing like
it just does everything so goddamn well
yeah yeah exactly well I guess why it's
like [ __ ] number two on IMDb yeah I
mean do you think that you do you think
medical saw is better than Breaking Bad
now that it's over
that's tough
um I think if you had to pick one of the
two
I think Breaking Bad offers a more
complete package of
hitting every kind of emotion Saul is a
very very slow burn yes that really
believes that in its storytelling and
its characters to to tell an amazing
story yes it knows that the characters
of in the universe are so strong that
they can really slow it down yeah and
and you know because the first two
seasons it's a very very slow burn not
that much happens and it's like for two
seasons it's very slow it's all just
setting the stage building up these
characters showing you why they're going
to be why they are and it's like it's so
rare to see a prequel that
almost improves on what the main thing
did and kind of offers even more reason
to go back and watch the first the
original like
you know the Jimmy's character of Saul
in Breaking Bad is is very funny very
funny loyal man but it just makes
medical Soul turns him into this amazing
grounded character where you can
understand why he went down the paths he
went down yeah just it's just a great
drama it's it but it's slow it's very
slow yeah I think that's why Breaking
Bad might just Edge it out for me right
Breaking Bad just hits the ground
running right yeah probably because he
had to do a pilot and whereas medical
Soul could had the had the brand had
more Wiggles Yeah well yeah I mean the
reason I think a lot of people wouldn't
watch Better Call Saul or wouldn't have
got past the first season if they didn't
know it was part of Breaking Bad because
it is just it it just trusts that you
want to see the payoff right yeah I I
think I've got a perfect analogy of why
I
I'm not personally attached to Breaking
Bad
so Breaking Bad is like if you built an
AI computer
and you programmed it to write the
perfect TV show that would be Breaking
Bad okay you know like it feels like it
is the perfect TV show with with correct
Spanish in it apparently the Spanish is
Dreadful I don't know apparently
apparently the Spanish is like
unwatchable Spanish people I'm so sorry
Spanish people but at least a medical
Soul they have an actual uh Spanish
person uh playing a character and he's
really [ __ ] good yeah no Gustavo is
not even remotely Spanish oh and
apparently his Spanish is Dreadful oh
really yeah apparently it's [ __ ]
unbearable uh because he's supposed to
be playing a Chilean dude yeah but he's
uh from like Denmark or something and
has African descent oh so there's no
Spanish ties remotely
um so people are like bro his Hispanic
should yeah yeah that's that's I think
that's that's what I mean it's like it
feels like the perfect TV show but it
feels so good that it feels like it was
written by a computer and why would you
not want it so you say so what you're
basically saying is that like some flaws
in the show are good because
guys I actually rotted your brain I mean
it has okay I'm not but like sometimes
okay even watch like sometimes one of my
favorite things is kind of like feeling
a connection between the person who made
this particular thing like this
particular piece of fiction
um I like feeling like there is I
understand what they're trying to
portray or Express you know with
Breaking Bad I Feel Complete coldness
because I feel it's just amazing it's
perfectly written but I don't know what
you know so there's nothing wrong with
like the like a show being like
inherently perfect in its writing or
like incredibly good in this writing
yeah like you need some kind of thing
that gives you a connection between you
as a viewer and the person who made it
trying to express themselves through the
world I mean I mean that's why even
Kenny was like
it was like one of my favorite anime of
all time you know it doesn't doesn't
necessarily have to make sense I wonder
if that's just a person by person thing
because I feel like I get it oh it's
definitely a person I I feel like I
understand the messages they're trying
to put out and the feelings they're
trying to portray yeah I feel it's the
same thing with music it's like
sometimes you just want to listen to a
good song and not give a [ __ ] about who
it's made by you know sometimes you want
to be like well I need to care about the
song Because I want to care about this
person yeah who made it yeah I know
Chris loves medical Souls